all right so will there never any stream
of zero experienced Hunter scandals ever
stop new report says Kevin Morris that's
the famed Hollywood attorney that some
describes as Hunter's sugar brother has
been supporting him financially and
legally through his endless troubles
while Jonathan Turley highlighted this
in his latest New York Post column now
messages reveal that at the height of
the scrutiny into a shady business
dealings the bidens offered Hunter quote
Safe Harbor from his growing problems
here with reaction author of the brand
new book just out today it's a great
book I've been reading it trial of the
century hannity.com amazon.com
bookstores all around the country Fox
News legal analyst Greg Jarrett by the
way immediately following the show he
has a live book signing you can get a
first print signed edition I will be his
guest at about 10 15 tonight Eastern 7
15 on the west coast uh and just go to
gregjarrettbook.com and New York Post
reporter John Levine is with us uh thank
you both Greg first congratulations in
the book and thank you you know what do
we know about this sugar brother as he's
being described you know the guy paid
all this money and Hunters back taxes
you know did he pay much did he pay
taxes on the this money has anyone
scrutinized it to any level in terms of
legality of all this that seems like a
odd relationship to me yeah no kidding I
mean hunter Biden who claims he's
destitute lives in a palatial mansion in
Malibu he drives a fancy Carneys flying
around uh on his sugar daddy six million
dollar jet uh all the while he's selling
his kindergarten Finger Paintings for
six figures probably to the same Chinese
benefactors that funneled 31 million to
the Biden family as for the lawyer look
it's been described as a two million
dollar loan to pay off the uh IRS debt
um and that would appear to be a
violation of the code of conduct that
governs lawyers you're not allowed to
loan money except for min minimal living
expenses and advancing the cost of
litigation not two million dollars worth
He also appears to be entangled in
Hunter Biden's businesses at least one
of them and again that's forbidden by
the canons of Ethics so it strikes me
the bar association should be
investigating yeah you know John I look
at this Comey McCabe struck page none of
them held accountable they weren't even
interviewed uh in terms of the Durham
report which shocks me especially in
light of what we now know and and what
that what that report said so you know
everybody's watching day in and day out
we report all this news the FBI has had
the laptop since December of 2019 we
know there's low hanging fruit of crimes
committed on the laptop nothing happens
why should anyone have faith in our
justice system if you know nothing
happens unless you're a Republican
I mean I can report that very few people
do have faith in the justice system
anymore I mean there's certainly no
republicans in Congress that have any
faith in Christopher Ray and if
Republicans take back the White House in
2024 I expect he'll probably be fired
you know the FBI's Litany of failures on
Hunter Biden have been going on since at
least 2019 when they as you mentioned
they had the laptop and didn't move on
it and then they've been allegedly
investigating Hunter Biden since 2018
the Department of Justice and we haven't
seen any progress in that case and just
for some comparison that's been a six
almost a six-year investigation we have
seen people who were involved in January
6. try arrested tried convicted served
their sentence and released all in the
span of time that Hunter Biden has been
being investigated by the Department of
Justice with no consequences for his
behaviorating there is not a lot of
confidence now no I don't believe we
have equality and they didn't move on it
or application of our loss Greg
glasswork
I mean we just learned about the text
message from the president's brother Jim
Biden Hunter Biden this can work all the
deals are still alive I can work with
your father alone in other words the
machine had to keep going funneling
money from overseas into
biden-controlled bank accounts and it
wasn't just Hunter Biden that was
involved the president's brother and
documents show that the president
himself may have been complicit yeah
well at the end of this if this
continues might as well take that great
document known as our Constitution and
shred it because it's meaningless uh by
the way Greg congrats on the book trial
of the century I will be with you at 10
15 this evening Eastern Time Greg
jarrettbook.com you'll be doing a live
signing I'm going to check in and say
hello I look forward to it and uh best
of luck and bookstores all around the
country hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else